I may be returning officer an election
of a member of parliament if I give
notice that the number
No
thank you can I start by thanking the
office early morning agents of the
accounting agents are all their hard
work today we all say it's a pretty much
more enjoyable cabin he was five years
ago Macbeth later in the afternoon and
like the 20s or secure account like to
thank by whole campaign team my family
my wife Alice for their support
everyone's been a long campaign very
much appreciated and it said I makers
are riveted and I think obviously what
we've seen here today is uber bamber
valley have chosen a strong servant of
government to continue the actions you
need to get the country out and
messaging take the cultural in the right
direction i'm very honored of a
productive to be elected for a second
term because of the people about the
valley where HIV to to my fellow
candidates really very strong robust but
overall a positive campaigns that before
to mutate your tributes to democracy in
our value in the coming election fault
in this place an autistic way and i just
like to make everyone we support this
time
you